it's christmas morning in just two weeks
hopefully you've noticed
right now the marine corps is working
hard to make sure every child in the
valley has a toy for the holiday season
this morning kate houston is live at a
warehouse up in the north part of the
valley where marines are going through
all donations for toys for tots good
morning kate
good morning yes our local marines will
be working tirelessly over the next few
weeks
to sort all of these toys here thousands
of toys
all of these boxes having to go through
them and sort them by different
age groups it's all part of their annual
toys for tots drive
now although they collect toys every
year due to the pandemic there are some
changes
this year the marine corps added a new
way to donate through their partnership
with amazon wish list
this option allows community members to
donate virtually
instead of at a traditional drop-off
site you can make your virtual donation
on their website through next tuesday
that's december 15th and although it's
been a difficult year for
many organizations the marine corps was
able to partner with 183 non-profits
to ensure that toys for tots happens now
they project there will be enough
donations to provide toys
to 23 000 kids in southern nevada this
christmas
every child deserves christmas and
anything that can be given will be much
appreciated
being able to provide that in the in the
time that we have
currently has been has been an awesome
feeling
and we can we hope to continue providing
that
for years to come right now toys for
tots is
struggling to get donations for certain
age groups they need toys for boys and
girls
ages 0 to 2 as well as 11
to 14. now if you don't want to donate
virtually
you can always drop off a toy in person
to boxes that look just like these ones
here there are 234 of them
across las vegas and you can drop that
toy off in person
through december 16th reporting live
from the warehouse
on speedway boulevard and i-15 kate
houston 8 news now do what you can if
you can
kate thank you very much